[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and a couple of
things coming up you should know about
one is there's a reception afterwards
over the long now
Museum and shop half a block that way
the next speaker line ad is arias is
actually Daniel Suarez for dyslexic he
wrote a novel which you can get outside
called Damon or demon being the computer
technical term for a certain kind of
quasi a I bought my wife is reading the
book right now and it's defeating sleep
for it's an incredibly well-written book
and he's going to come and do something
for first time which is talk about the
ideas behind that book in the sequel
which is coming called freedom TM
trademark September 9th Neal
Stephenson's new book Anitha will be
world launched from here with long now
and that's partly because he got the
idea for the book from the clock belong
now and there will be live music it's a
sort of a monastic order that goes with
the 10,000 Alinea McLaughlin
mathematical and there's some singers
who have developed that sort of music
and they're going to perform it live
Neal will read from the book and Danny
Hillis and Neil will talk about the book
and everything else
that'll be September 9th we're not sure
where yet we want to have it somewhere
echoey so the music reverberates the way
it should
September 9th is a Tuesday night
the clock Danny Hillis is ten thousand
Alexandra roses ten thousand year
o'clock it's a work of art it's a land a
piece of land art and away a piece of
conceptual art in the way and a piece of
engineering more importantly and art is
about art so the sign that you've got
some art that's up to something is when
it makes other artists do things that
might not otherwise have done so in the
US Neal Stephenson's book is one of
those and what we'll see tonight is
another the great photographer Edward
Burtynsky
I Thank You Stuart it's really exciting
to be here in San Francisco again I
always enjoy coming to San Francisco and
I really thought about how I ended up
doing this talk and and it came as a
result of two dinners one dinner with
Danny Hillis about a year ago and he was
telling me more about the 10,000 year
clock and the idea of it the inception
of it what what the intention of it is
and how it's supposed to function out
there which I was all ears and out of
that conversation I said you know that
this really reminds me of some other
things that I've heard about James
Charles Roden crater you know the
Lightning fields of walter de maria
other types of land art pieces out there
that kind of encourage a pilgrimage to
it for those who who are really
interested in the arts are interested in
conceptual ideas are interested in land
art or interested in in concepts that
this kind of place that has something
very special going on i think captures
our imagination today when were
inundated with homogeneity and and you
know and that everything is becoming
more and more the same one of the things
we buy the things we drive the things we
live in so and also how we think about
things like this particular project
captured my imagination because at first
i thought now in in the day and age
where we're all talking about global
warming and trying to figure out how to
make it to the next 50 hundred years it
doesn't seem to be a little odd to be
talking about a clock that can run by
itself for ten thousand years and i just
thought you know is this really where we
should be paying our paying attention
right now when when you know when you
know we've got the you know a fire in
the kitchen
and and we're trying to think about you
know how to design our next you know
living room out on the edge of our house
and i thought this is kind of an odd
place to be right now especially for
thinkers you know like Danny and
Alexander
and then the long now and then I started
to hear more about well why what is it
that that makes this a compelling idea
for our time and and I think again it's
it's what what it is that the foundation
has come to is that we have I was just
reading a press release that Brian Eno
had had done when he talked about doing
the chimes by the way the the music
you're hearing were the experimental
chimes that would be part of the clock
when you were coming in but he was
saying we've come to a point both our
politicians our corporate leaders
everybody is thinking in very short
terms the next quarter the next election
the next next but it's not it's not to
any distant future we're not thinking
even 10 20 30 years out we're just
thinking just ahead of where we are
right now which is a kind of thinking
that gets us into serious trouble as we
all I think can appreciate that there
are definite issues with that that kind
of short-term thinking and so when when
I was talking to Donnie Danny at this
dinner I said well I like the idea that
you begin to start to shape the way you
think because everything then all your
materials all the way your thinking is
about this future it's not only very
optimistic it it's also very creative in
that well how do we begin to make
something of enduring quality and that
making of something of enduring quality
forces us out of short-term thinking and
and it's as simple as that so when I
heard this I said well Danny you know I
think it would be really interesting if
someone's gonna make a pilgrimage to to
see this clock in this mountain and this
chamber in this mountain wouldn't it be
interesting to do something more to give
that person who made the pilgrimage a
little bit more to digest when they get
there why not do a gallery of of images
within the within the chamber of the
clock and you kind of turn to me he said
you know all the ideas and I get lots of
ideas of what to do
you along with a clock I really like
this idea and I'm sorry Danny wanted to
be here tonight but he's extremely busy
right now and he's promised to look at
the videos so I expect you to look at
the video so Danny so anyways yeah so he
he really thought that this was a
beautiful coming together of ideas that
he liked it and he said I'd like to you
to think more about that and find out
more about that so I started researching
and and so that was the first dinner
that got me to stand here tonight the
second one was with Stuart about five
months ago six months ago in here in San
Francisco and it was after an exhibition
of mine on Cory's we were having a
dinner and Stuart really means and we
were talking about this and he said I
think you should talk about this at one
of at one of our talks and I went gee I
never thought of doing a talk on it but
sure I'll certainly try to put these
thoughts together and present them to to
the audience here so this is the first
time I'm presenting this idea it's been
an interesting journey in that I didn't
know where I was going to end up I just
started to pull away at tug at ideas and
you know I'll talk about them as I go
through it but the gallery of the 10,000
year clock this is a quick little
proposal that I put forward this is a
proposal to create a gallery of
permanent images to be exhibited in the
chamber of the 10,000 year clock this
clock will have the ambition and
capacity to keep accurate time without
human intervention for a period of
10,000 years
the clock would be installed in a
chamber within a mountain and be powered
by the cycles of day and night the
gallery will display 20 plus images
curated by a variety of current thinkers
an image specialist who will be asked to
select a group of images that would
reflect the impulse of the cape painters
of Glasgow that could loosely be defined
by this quote from Wenzel Van Heusen who
is an expert in in the caves the
paintings are the oldest symbols of
human imagination and they certainly had
some religious and mythological meaning
they tell us about who our direct
ancestors were what they thought and
what they could do they tell us about
imagination about creativity about
consciousness
about the Creator the clock and the
mountain that contains that will enter
into the realm of destinations worthy of
pilgrimage to witness and experience
those who make that effort would be
rewarded not only with the Marvel of the
clock but also a contemporary update to
the impulses of the K painters of
Lascaux an exhibition of images that the
curators believe represent the creative
expressions values desires and concerns
of our current culture the images that
are selected will not necessarily be a
complete compendium of our value system
thus reading like a time capsule for
future generations rather it will
reflect contemporary manifestations of
our individual and collective will I can
imagine it exhibitions along the
following lines are built world using
nature Science and Technology objects of
desire notions of beauty mobility energy
freedom in the middle class conflict
Darwin versus God pursuit of outer space
and the cosmos and so on and unlike the
painters of Alaska who were not painting
for the enlightenment of future
generations but for the benefits and
values we today live with extended
consciousness and cannot help but
consider what might be interesting to
leave behind a symbolic representation
of who we are and what we aspire to so
that that's kind of the the working
parameter of what I I was beginning to
think about in doing the clock and so
the clock itself I don't know how many
I'm sure many of you are familiar with
it this is the first prototype and and
it exists in the Science Museum and in
the in London and I think it's that
correct it's in London yeah so it's into
the science museum and this is obviously
a pair down version and what's
interesting about this clock is again
the materials that are being used how
it's being conceived to keep accurate
time over a period of 10,000 years
without human intervention this is a
really fascinating I think scientific
problem in physics and materials and and
I think it's you know again something of
incredible curiosity that that something
can
kind of again drive itself over that
period of time and I thought I kept
asking Danny well what is going to be is
it gonna be like a windmill or solar you
said no no none of that stuff is more
than 50 100 years and we're talking so
basically the the premise here is that
they're going to have some type of wires
that expand and contract at a high rate
outside that can capture the energy of
expansion contraction through the Sun
and and through the cold of the night
and and the heat of the day also there's
going to be a slot within the mountain
that at the zenith would be able to set
the time so it can recalibrate itself on
a daily basis so this is something that
is meant to be kept keep very accurate
time over a long period of time the
mountain itself and Mount Washington is
is currently you know the mountain of
choice it's up and one can go to this
mountain today and and I think that if
I'm not mistaken that somewhere along up
into this area a slot will be cut where
the zenith of the Sun can be picked up
and and it can recalibrate itself from
that some other shots of the mountain so
this mountain is also now in possession
I think of or available to be developed
into a chamber and has the the
conditions of you know that the rock is
solid enough that it's impermeable that
it can withstand a fair amount of of
jostling should an earthquake occur and
still maintain its structure all these
conditions of what the chamber how the
chamber can be built to withstand
because chambers change over time too
and and so all these types of all this
type of thinking is being brought to
creation the creation of the chamber
within this mountain
now the chamber itself there is no
current design but Danny was nice enough
to send me a whole bunch of things that
he found interesting as chambers as
underground structures this is the the
Russian subway system being the
constructed this is the salt chambers
outside of Warsaw that were these large
carved chambers with sculptures are
there for the public viewing this is in
France it's a Cathedral in France these
are the sewers in in Japan and if any of
you have seen them they're pretty wild
and this is more of an organic type of
chamber entering down into and into a
cave I think this is in France as well
so the gallery 10,000 so the caves of
Lascaux in a way these these are some of
the earliest paintings they some of them
date back twenty thirty thousand years
beautifully drawn and this is one of the
few figures that appears and it's
actually a figure of a fallen hunter but
it most of them are just animals and
Spears and but but here's one of the few
a few figures again probably
representing the greatest consequence of
the hunters to lose a battle to to to
the animal and to give up their life in
pursuit of the hunt and and again there
I've not had a chance to to ever see
them but but they are the the impulse of
these of the painters again was not to
to send messages to us but to again lay
down what their system of thinking what
was important to them during during
their their lives and and and again I
wanted to keep to that idea that I don't
want necessarily a time capsule with the
images but but to try to call out the
kinds of things that reach rule II
represent our culture and then the big
question was well I'm a photographer and
why not go back to these types of
paintings why why photography and so for
a long time I kept thinking can I make a
case for photography being the
the the medium of choice to have
exhibitions of the photographic process
some of you may be familiar with his
Nisa food and uses photo first
photograph so this is the first fixed
image ever that was that still exists
today in in eighteen I think 38 was the
the date that this was formed very
primitively
it took a whole day to expose it but
from this image all images have cascaded
forward I mean before that was a camera
obscura where they could still see the
image on the back of the ground glass
for almost 200 years
no one knew how to fix it and finally
there was a way to capture again
primitive but all of a sudden it says
yes it can be done and it's from the
capturing of this image that all future
images came out of so if we think of you
know the still motion picture video
multimedia all of that starts with this
very simple primitive image and what I
started to think about is well it's a
direct outcome the photographic image is
a direct outcome of the Industrial
Revolution it's really part of the
process part of the handling of
chemicals and materials and plastics and
and dichromate sand and and light
sensitive thing you know materials
understanding cameras and optics and
lenses and all of that are all really a
direct result and that photography
coming into being we shape it as human
beings we create the images and find
ways to refine them but at the same time
those images are shaping us in a
powerful way
and I think if if I look back at the
last 150 years of photography it has
told us more about ourselves and any
previous histories in painting or
anything that all of a sudden the
photograph was a ubiquitous form it
wasn't too expensive to make it wasn't
just the enclave of the bourgeois and
the church and the state now all of a
sudden everyone everyone had a chance to
make images or be an image through a
portrait and and it changed the way we
saw ourselves had changed the way we
began to understand the world around us
and it began to
many of the things that we couldn't
understand or didn't see because they
were outside of our consciousness so the
photograph so if there was a war the
Boer War or any all of a sudden these
images the Vietnam War all of a sudden
these images started to come back to us
and we began to learn from these images
what these consequences were what that
other world that's going on out there
that we hear about but don't see and
when we see I think because photography
is part of everyone's life now I think
if I was to say to everybody in this
room when you think of yourself
and growing up what what kinds of things
come to mind and I bet you many of the
thing images of that your past homes
your bedroom when you were five and
you're the bike you rode and the clothes
you wore when you're young are all
probably attached to early images that
we have memories of that time but a
picture of you at five when you look
back at it when you're 50 will tell you
more and key you right back into that
place like nothing else will and our
histories our personal histories are
linked to photography as is our larger
collective social histories linked to
photography and that it's through that
medium that I believe we interpret our
world and again shape our world as
photography shapes us and that was
really the the reason why I felt that
this indexical relationship that Darvey
is as imprint of the world and that this
print represents that imprint that again
made the justification for wanting to
use that as the key medium within the
10,000 year cave so then I thought well
carbon transfer print that brings me to
well if I was going to do a photographic
print what print would I do and and at
first I thought well I want to do
something that is reasonably you know
practical and that I could actually have
some confidence that it will
we'll be there in a cave now I'm
assuming a cave is going to be in dark
storage for long periods of time I'm
also making an assumption that cabinets
can be built
then when the exhibition is brought down
it can be pushed into cabinets that are
fairly well sealed from humidity as well
as the cave and the clock needs to have
a fairly stable temperature and humidity
as well so I'm assuming the conditions
for the clock are also going to be
fairly ideal conditions for a print and
and and I talked to say Danny needs that
that's a fair assumption to make so then
I said okay well based on that
assumption what is the most permanent
process I could find and I and that's
practical and I thought well inkjet we
all know what ink Jets are we all know
that there's a lot of development in
that in that field and I started to
think well if there were an inkjet
printer that had pure very good CMYK
being samma gentle yellow black and if
it could jet these pigments onto a
material that doesn't corrode a paper or
a mylar or something that I felt had a
10,000 year stability to it then bingo
I've got it and then I just have to find
that but in my search of inkjet printers
that could jet the same inks that that
would be used to paint a car so I was
saying a car if we think of a car out
there in the Sun every day getting
blasted by the Sun and not changing
color very much whatever is in those
pigments should withstand you know
centuries in millennia of time in a
fairy quality controlled or humidity
controlled cave the thing I could not
find was any process that had evolved
the kinds of technologies that would
spray on the paint onto cars onto a
perfect CMYK printing process and even
if it were there
there were kind of noises that somebody
was close to it I didn't feel at this
point in time that you know with all the
other
types of materials that would have to be
brought in to bring those pigments to a
point that could be jet able and the
breaking down of those pigments that
there was anything that I would have in
the next five to ten years that could
give me any assurance like a Henry
Wilhelm test any assurance that this has
a go-forward stability so that was my
first pursuit and it kind of ended in no
I don't think I've got an answer here so
I continued to pull away at things and I
did look at the dye transfer process
which no longer as possible because
Kodak dropped the dye transfer process
and they made all the matrices for it
and so that in the late 80s early 90s
was a process that was no longer there
so then I went further and actually went
back to a process that was developed in
around 1855 and it's called the the
carbon the carbon transfer process and
I'm going to read you a bit about it in
the history of it the carbon transfer
process is considered by most persons
who know it to be one of the most
beautiful of all photographic processes
carbon prints are capable of a wide
range of image characteristics that can
be virtually any color or tone and the
final image can be placed on a wide
variety of surfaces including glass
metal paper as well as various kinds of
synthetic surfaces when the final
support has a smooth surface Carbon
sorry when the final support has a
smooth relief that gives them a real
dimensional quality especially prominent
when the photograph has held sideways to
the light Carbon is without question the
most distinctive and stable of all
photographic processes with the
capability of presenting images with a
wide range of image characteristics of
virtually any color or tone on a wide
variety of surfaces finally carbon
transfer prints which are made up of
inner pigments suspended in a hardened
gelatin colloid are the most stable of
all photographic prints so what you're
looking at here is a carbon transfer
print and what I'd like to show you
quickly is is basically I have to jump
out of my
to show this to you because this is on
the web so this is basically what's
happening you create that size of that
image you create a negative digitally so
what's that used to be done filming by
by separating a color slide or whatever
through an RGB and making Meg's nowadays
you digitize the transparency or the
negative and then you convert it into
for black and white high contrast
lithographic negatives through a digital
process and and that's what you're
seeing in the tray here or on the light
table is a digitized black and white
negative once you have the negatives
made you then move to and I have samples
of it there that's actually the carbon
and pigments so these are I brought some
as well these are the pigments so you
have your cyan blue now this is these
all come from quarries this is stone
ground up into very very fine fine
powder and then suspended in an emulsion
so that's your cyan your yellow and your
magenta so those are then you also have
a black but those are the key colors
black is very ubiquitous it's not it's
not hard to find black carbon but those
colors come from specific minds that
have stone of that color that are ground
up and there's nothing else in them and
then they're just suspended and once the
the stone is suspended they're turned
into these types of sheets these are
light-sensitive sheets so so that is
then then the there that's a mixture of
sugar that the the the pigment is
suspended in and dichromats and also
which which is a light-sensitive aspect
of it and also there's a gelatin that
and then it's mixed to a certain
viscosity and then rolled out onto this
paper once it's rolled out onto the
paper you expose it so this is a typical
exposing device so it's a very high
intensity light so you're exposing
through the negative
to the material which wants any light
that comes through hardens that color
and once that color is hard and it can
then be washed out so you've now got it
and now what you do what you're going to
do here is you wash out all of the
material that hasn't been exposed to
light and it washes away and what you're
left with is is the material so these
are the four layers being being shown so
this is how it's being built up each
layer is pulled and transferred and
what's happening is that you're using
this here which is gelatin and this
gelatin has been around which is
basically marrow from from the cow from
the bones of the cow and so the gelatin
is it's a pure gelatin it doesn't yellow
it doesn't crackle it's been around for
fifteen hundred years and this is what
allows the different layers to adhere to
each other and then once you have all
these layers adhering to each other then
you can take all of them together and
transfer them onto a water color paper
the water color papers read two sources
of watercolor papers that are that are
known to be able to withstand the test
of time they're about 300 grams some of
the thickest papers you can you can find
out they're built extremely well and you
know papers that van Gogh was using
these the Fabriano and arches are the
two key ones Italian Fabriano arches is
French these are the two key suppliers
of paper when I looked at possibly doing
this one can transfer this onto
porcelain which seems like a much more
stable material one of the issues is
porcelain that I voted the porcelain
down on and that would be a beautiful
print but when the reasons was one human
intervention somebody could drop for the
porcelain and it would it would
disappear would be shatter into many
many pieces the second concern about
porcelain was that if there were
there are a lot of temperature variation
over time that the gelatin silver may be
tested in other words the the layer the
emulsion layer may be tested against
that layer it's on at the expansion and
contraction is much higher than the
image is and you can start breaking the
bonds between the the the image and the
material that it's holding it together
whereas when you get this gelatin
against this paper the bonds go very
very deep into the structure of the
paper therefore if you have temperature
variations the chances of a failure of
the image where it begins to let go and
curl up or break away from the paper is
reduced to nil it's almost impossible
then to separate the the image from the
paper so as long as nothing happens to
the paper that the containment that the
paper sits in after the exhibition is in
a watertight pretty airtight dark
chamber I can't imagine that if you open
that chain that up irregularly and then
but any any time you can open it up all
the time under dim light and never see a
change I would think as long as water
never got in there and damaged the paper
that these would indeed still be there
ten thousand years from now on this
paper and on this with this pigment
there there is the chance as well that
something in ten years five to ten years
may come about some kind of ink jetting
process that that may all of a sudden
have a breakthrough and that I think
would be an exciting moment right now
just to give you an idea this is one of
the largest sizes they can go without a
lot of failure they they can there's
really about three places in the world
that can do this one's in Cornwall in
the UK ones in Seattle and ones in
Toronto I've been dealing with both the
Seattle and the Toronto I also went to
see the the gentleman doing Gerrard
doing him in
in the UK but the one the one that's
most promising is is Todd who's doing
them in Seattle and that's the website
you're seeing is art and soul that's his
his site where he does does these prints
you can do in that size the product the
price for one of them at that size is
about two thousand dollars 30 40 s if
he's up to doing them and it's very
difficult to do them they wouldn't be
full 30 40 would be 30 40 watercolor
paper they I think the price would jump
to about four or five thousand per print
so very very labor-intensive takes about
five days from beginning to end a
process to get one color image in the
carbon so it's very artisan very
hands-on very very few there's a handful
that I think there's maybe less than ten
people probably on the planet today that
can make that print so so it is again
something that if the ten thousand year
gallery were to become a real thing
there may be a chance to revive a craft
I think for this to find a way to Stu to
capture the materials for a long period
of time until some other permanent
process comes into play so that's and if
anybody wants to come up later and just
look at the print or feel them and those
the different colors you're welcome to
play with that so what I did to keep
that interesting as I said okay well I
wouldn't want to curate every show I
think that would be a huge burden and I
don't think that would be very
interesting so I asked a couple of my
colleagues nearby who who would do it
without charging me and and I said would
you would you just put together an idea
if I said here's the chamber you've
curated you're a professional curator
you created shows you know spend a week
or so think about it put something
together you know call your own work of
what you've done in the past so vid is
vid Engle vixx's is a great friend of
mine and he's created many many he's
interested in Musial adji is interested
in very interest
staying views of how we look at the
world
so his working title was called the
Museum of the mundane and this is what
he writes it is a relatively that is
relatively recently that questions
around representation class gender and
the nature of the everyday have come
together to influence the scope of
history whether written or as the
subject of museological display the turn
to the everyday past as an object of
study has meant an expansion of
interests beyond the activities of
royalty the extraordinary to include the
prosaic free occupations of the
shoemaker Baker or office clerk the
greater that's in poor old distance
between ourselves and the past the more
intense popular and professional
interest in the mundane seems to become
as one example the graffiti often
pornographic found on the walls of the
rune Pompeian walls now attract more
attention from both tours and
archaeologists as the elegant mosaic
floors the town's wealthy inhabitants
accordingly I would propose to work with
the elements of the banal the mundane
and the everyday of our era there are
two possible approaches I am considering
for this initial proposal the first
would produce a kind of photographic
Museum of the mid-century banal to
highlight ordinary commercially
available products popular in the mid
20th century as drawn from photography
collections found in two major Canadian
archives those of the Library and
Archives Canada National Design Council
archives and the archives of Ontario
Eaton's department store archives
Eaton's is actually one of the largest
department stores that when are the
business about ten years ago they've
been in Canada for almost a hundred
years the accompanying 20 images are
drawn from these two sources further
research at other sites could of course
be carried out if deemed necessary
the second approach would involve the
reproduction in some visual form of the
material goods and ambience found in a
typical corner convenience store or
dollar store
the two sites each have their
attractions the very notion of
convenience is itself part of the ethos
of our time with the range of products
functioning by default as a kind of
unofficial poll of what we feel are the
true necessities of life
cat food milk bread lottery tickets
double-a batteries cigarettes etc as for
the dollar store it can be seen as being
a repository of simulacra based on the
world of commercially derived objects
outside its doors the dollar store
shelves are packed with goods that are
basically cheap reproductions of
existing things thus engaging with
issues of representation desire and
class in our time I would propose that
for North Americans as these kinds of
places that unerringly provide the
authentic texture of the ordinary life
of our time so what's interesting is is
when I first saw this proposal I thought
Jesus aren't the most exciting pictures
I've ever seen
but they are interesting in that I kept
thinking of them as if if we were doing
an archaeological dig of some
civilization 10,000 years ago we'd be
digging up their spear heads or
arrowheads we'd be digging up you know
their pots and shards of pots and and
these were the things that will comprise
their daily lives and in many ways these
are the things that that are part of our
daily lives and that archaeologists will
be digging up you know if they are out
there in ten or fifteen or twenty
thousand years and going to our dump
sites will be finding just these kinds
of things and obviously in different
states of decay but but I did think it
was a different way to begin to again
lay something down for a you know a
Museum of the ten thousand year clock
that or the gallery to put something
that somehow you know isn't a how she
would say a celebration of what we
do but it's really more of an
archeological dig of who we are and the
kinds of things that we surround
ourselves with in our day to day lives
to lead the kind of lives that that we
lead of course I know if any of you had
this hockey game or this is just a
Canadian thing or not I'm not sure these
are all the animals in Canada that you
could find I'll turn into little plastic
animals so something everybody should
have so then I went to another friend of
mine and Marcus Schubert and said can
you go and you know see what you come up
with just just again apply yourself to
it and he came up with something where
he didn't want to use again any of his
own imagery because he's a photographer
in his own right but he wanted to go so
he just literally went on to the web so
none of it none of this has got a
copyright approval this is all just
hypothetical here so so he went and
collected all this stuff and and he
referred to the project observations
from a blue planet and he took he took
the line an exhibition in my proposal an
exhibition of images that represented
creative expressions values desires and
concerns of our current culture in my
proposal and he he kind of ripped off of
that and this is what he says presented
in the form of diptych s-- the
photographs in this presentation explore
a range of similarities and differences
both within the framework of each
pairing and in concert with the other
diptych s-- in the series all the images
are called from internet sources then
recontextualized by juxtaposition to
create discrete meanings that two
meanings to relate to the dynamics of
our human condition these specific
selections may be seen as sketches to
hint at what could be a more
comprehensive investigation a world is a
cosmic oasis blessed with an atmosphere
profoundly rare in the universe
sustaining a vast system of biodiversity
that is nothing short of miraculous
however we live in a world of extremes
extremes of technological development
impoverishment wealth extremes of
weather of violence against one another
and a beauty in a few short centuries we
have ventured forward from the first
printed page to telephone networks and
now the internet we evolved from the use
of horses as transportations to the
pioneering of mechanical flight and
scientific deep-space exploration to
manned land landings upon the moon since
the discovery and development of fossil
fuel as a plentiful and versatile source
of energy civilization has experienced
staggering population growth and
technological advancement along with an
equally staggering polarization of
wealth I see the earth and its
inhabitants as participants in the
unfolding of a great dramatic experiment
an experiment of diversification and
consumption in less than a century for
the first time in recorded history we
have become increasingly aware that our
actions directly affect the viability of
our existence and that of our fellow
creatures humankind in this century can
now effectively be considered powerful
as a force of nature in the scale and
consequence of the effects and akanchha
of our actions upon the planet these
images are mere shadows on a cave wall
that intimate life as we know it the
question remains what kind of life is it
ideally my vision for an exhibition in
the 10,000 year gallery would be a prod
to would be to project 10,000 diptych
images in a grid forming a random
rolling sequence of images throughout
the space however if electrical power
constraints in such a remote location
inhibits the use of computers and
projectors alternative the production
and exhibition of a set of archival
prints as per specifications set forth
by the organizers would become the final
form of this presentation the pawns
further talking to him he thought it
would be interesting to use the site of
the long now to to bring in these types
of diptych sand to have a constant while
all
this is functional to have a constant
exhibition of these dip dicks as part of
the project as well so again as you can
see he's he's finding images that many
of them are within the the haves and the
have-nots category as I said to him
these these things are also paradises or
the power or the force of nature it's
his most tranquil and idyllic paradise
and it's damaging forceful nature so
these were these were again
some of his ideas that he felt were
salient and powerful representations
through the photographic medium that
that talked to to the things that affect
our time
this is one of the first switchboards
and on the right is an artist's
rendering of the world wide web so this
brings me around to a project I'm
calling in the wake of progress which is
I've edited down I think I've got a few
more than the 20 plus but I had a hard
time editing but what I wanted sorry
what I wanted to show in this work and
my own work was to again look at the
survey of my work but if I had to pick
in 30-plus images what would I pick and
why and as some of you may know my work
has has always been interested in trying
to reconnect us to what I call the the
the great ages of man the Stone Age the
Iron Age the Copper Age Bronze Age and
now we're in the you know Industrial
Revolution technological Information Age
but those earlier ages are still alive
and well and functioning on a scale on
our planet that I think many of us I
felt even I was unaware of until I began
this project over 25 years ago and so I
really began to think of well what's
happened what's changed I mean we've
always taken from the earth but
something's happened in the last couple
of eight years in particularly the last
century a lot of what I feel has
happened is number one the discovery of
oil the internal combustion engine
together there's cheap source of fuel
this incredibly powerful tool the
internal combustion engine has been able
to accelerate our abilities to to expand
and I think like any life force a life
force expands into its energy footprint
and with that energy footprint reduces
so does that life force and I believe
we're in this massive century of
expansion as a result of that energy of
the discovery of that non-renewable
resource called oil and I think if I go
back a hundred years where our
population was just breaking a billion
and in in a century we're now at 6.5
billion that increase is is
even from in my 50-plus years I think
when I was born the population was
around 2 to plus billion and now at 6.5
so that's almost you know 10 billion a
decade maybe 8 billion a decade and
that's that kind of growth is I'm asking
myself well how did that happen well if
we look at the transportation if we look
at fuel and ships and and and trains
cars farming equipment all of those
things have allowed us the ability to
expand at that dramatic rate so when I
went to think about how do I begin to
represent this one of the places I
thought was well the record series was
alone a first significant series I shot
an ad in 1983 and it was really the
opening up of North America that I was
thinking about that Europe was in a the
doldrums it was it was moving towards
North America to replenish its resources
and so I think you know America was born
of a European plunder so to speak if we
look at the European North America and
that the rail is a thing that opened up
the West and it opened it up rapidly
that this was you know this was you know
put in place about 170 years ago these
are the rails going through the rocky
but I wasn't photographing it kind of as
a heroic way I was trying to show it
straight on as I wanted to have us
contemplate with that with that line
that gesture through the landscape meant
to the landscape and to us and so it was
more of an image that makes us meditate
upon that engineered line and if one
looks at the actual you know the Train
its what is bearing is a load what's in
the load is the same colors amount and
so it is this kind of the mountain kind
of pouring into the cars filling them
with the material to be brought back to
the east to be brought back to Europe to
to fuel their continued expansion so to
me that it was an interesting way to
begin to look at our landscape and tell
a story
about what it means to us and and the
significance it has to to humankind and
to nature itself I then include I'm
including I would include several
pictures of minds and one of the things
when I photographed Minds
to move from the idea of the kind of
general that what's the biggest copper
mine in the world what's the biggest
iron ore mine in the world what how do I
go from that to the specific and that
and then the bigger is the keyword I
went in search of the largest examples
of of mines in the world so this is in
North America this is the largest copper
mine
it's a Kennecott Copper Mine just
outside of Salt Lake City and what to me
was interesting about this picture and
why I'd want to include it is that when
one looks at it one really begins to see
almost like an inverted pyramid it's a
big amphitheater but when you begin to
look at the scale of it and you see the
trains that these are actual you know
the this is a train in here and there's
a banana bus somewhere in here so when
you actually see that print you can see
these actual bits of information as what
they are and their size and then the
size begins to to present itself and
what I was thinking is that well these
are in a way this is the great sublime
of our time that the sublime has been
subverted from one that during Turner's
period during the Romantic period where
man was still dwarfed by nature the Moby
Dick story or or the ship being lost at
sea and a Turner painting that you know
this is no longer the fearful sublime
we've now built cars and planes and
ships to to be able to withstand those
types of forces and so this to me is is
is that is the new sublime the force of
human engineering and capacity to be
able to capture these materials and
convert them and isolate ourselves from
the the elements and in the isolating
ourselves from the elements we have
become an element in and of ourselves so
to me this is one of the ideas that I
like to think about when I started to
photograph these minds this in South
America is a chuquicamata mine I just
shot this a year ago and again the one
of the large this is I think the largest
mine the last to argue who's the biggest
but I think there's twenty five thousand
men that work here and they claim that
30% of all copper in the world comes
from this one mine where I'm standing
the opposite wall of that of this
particular mine is five kilometres away
so just to give you a sense of the scale
here and it's only about a third of the
way down there's still two-thirds to go
this is in Australia I just got back
last year again photographing this mine
this is a place called Mount Whaleback
one of the largest richest iron ore
deposits known in the world it still
isn't a big mine but the deposit itself
is on a world-class level that hasn't
been rarely found the iron ore coming
out of it is I mean actually the darker
just to show you this darker this is the
iron ore here when you're down in that
area you just pick up a chunk of rock
and it just feels like you're picking up
a chunk of steel it's it's 65% iron ore
and it's supplying pretty much 50%
it's a bhp this is the biggest mine in
the world it's now trying to buy tech
not as it's trying to buy result to
think of it a minute they're just trying
to take over which would become you know
by large scale the largest mine in the
world but but they supply about a major
amount of iron ore for China Korea and
Japan so all of this stuff is being
shipped from northern Australia through
Port Hedland into into those three
market places and directly from here and
I found this place by photographing the
largest steel plant in China and said
where's all your iron ore coming from
and they said
well back in Australia and then I ended
up in remote well back so I often trace
things back that way as well
I wanted to show that any any mind has
as a consequence of mining is the thing
called tailings if you're familiar with
the mining process this is a tailings
pond and it's northern Northern Ontario
and so what I'm standing on here is
about a 70 meter high six thousand acre
pond and what they do is they flow out
the when when they take or out whether
it's copper or or nickel or the actual
or itself is a very small percentage
maybe 5% of the ore that's the rest of
it is just ground up rock and they have
to then through a trawl assist or
different processes extract the minerals
out and then they flow the rest of the
rock out they can't put it back in the
hole they dug because there's continuing
to dig those consequential holes are
still highly mineralized so that the
orange here is actually iron ore that
hasn't been used because it's not worth
it to take iron ore from this particular
or tailings because if you have iron ore
mines like the one I just showed you so
they just flow this iron back into the
tailings pond because it's not worth
capturing but all the silver the nickel
the copper has been taken out so so
these are this is a consequence of any
mining operation is a tailings operation
so you can't have really one without the
other and so a representation of a
tailings pond became I think an
important aspect to show in in my my
exhibit I also felt that our built
worlds our cities use dimensional stone
verses or stuff that's converted to two
metals but we use concrete but stone is
also a very important component of our
buildings so I went in search of some of
the largest dimensional stone quarries
in the world and I ended up doing a lot
of work in Vermont so this is granite
coming out of
Granite Quarry kind of at its last legs
they're still doing some work in the
foreground but most of this has been
abandoned the reason why they've
abandoned it is because the fractured
stone you see doesn't allow for them to
pull blocks big enough to be viable
within the marketplace so once they
can't get viable blocks out then they
they leave and go to areas that are
again less fractured more solid in and
begin to quarry that so this is an
example of a quarry in North America
this is in Vermont then I also went to
Carrara and these these quarries were
made famous by Michelangelo where he
went to find his marble but again it's
some of the finest marble in the world
being quarried here and again I wanted
to show this kind of inverted
architecture the scale of our taking and
I think that both as an image the images
that make us want to look at these
places that draw us to consider these
these kinds of places there's also I
feel a great amount of information about
how we're extracting these materials
that become present in the work as well
and I think that is one of the the the
beauties of photography is that it can
be all you know can be a fairly
aesthetic work of art or ascetically
seeing a scene but within it is embodied
a lot of information that can be drawn
out of those photographs by those who
spend the time to look at them and to
try to understand what is actually going
on in these pictures this is also a
recent it's a different point of view
but these are several recent pictures I
took in Australia and again that kind of
the extraction of industries is almost
like a almost like a cavity that that is
you know showing the the withdrawal of
material from
from the surface of the planet and then
this is to me again around the same
minds this is how we're reshaping to
grab this material it's almost like
looking at the inner organisms of
ourselves of intestinal kind of tract
that again I felt showed that our body
and the human the human body and the
landscape share a kind of visual
similarity when seen through through the
photographic medium and that the that
the the surface of the earth is really a
skin as well and how we kind of shape
that skin has a profound effect on the
planet and then I began to think well at
this point in time at the where we sit
today the story can't be complete if we
didn't or if I didn't bring in the idea
of oil and this is a photograph I took
recently in in Canada in northern
Alberta and it's some of you may have
heard it's called the oil sands and if
you look at this this is actually one of
the most significant deposits of oil in
the world only this northern Alberta has
a second largest source of oil known oil
on the planet after Saudi Arabia from
their town from their drilling tests
basically a difference here though is
that this is this here is the overburden
so in the back here we have the the
boreal forest which is the second
largest forest in unadulterated force on
the planet after the Amazon and equal
and as a carbon sink almost to the
Amazon these are - if you know if the
Amazon is considered the right lung of
the world the boreal forest is the left
lung so it is a very important tract of
forest and and then this is so the force
is being cleared for this area this is
the overburden about 20 or 7 meters or
20 feet
and then here is the is where the oil is
coming from this is the oil sands and
this is about 60 to 70 feet deep and it
the area that can be mined this way is
close to the size of Florida and what's
happening is that here's a truck
carrying this 12% of that is bitumen
that can be converted into oil and the
rest of it is sand so what we have
happening here is that companies from
all around the world are now buying
leases in northern Alberta to extract
this particular fairly dirty oil I think
Al Gore spoke about the oil sands at the
last TED conference I thought what he
said was quite interesting he said if we
look at our human addiction to oil as a
junkie addicted to heroin going for the
oil sands is like shooting up between
our toes so if I kind of said it clearly
so anyways what's happening is and what
a lot of people don't understand in fact
recently what's spurred our government
Alberta government just to throw two
billion dollars out it is California
Thank You California the California was
saying we're not going to accept this
oil it's got too much of a carbon
footprint for our liking to accept it so
they're now trying to find ways to
sequester the carbon but but what's
happening is that to get this oil out
they have to create vast amounts of
steam and so basically for whatever the
co2 footprint for a barrel of oil
conventionally like Saudi Arabia oil
this is about four times more the co2
footprint to get this oil out so we're
burning natural gas to create a dirty
oil which is a fairly clean burning
fossil fuel for a very dirty burning
fossil fuel and so there's a lot of
discussion about sequestering this and
and I think it's high time that there's
this discussion were to happen and I was
very encouraged that California actually
stood up and said we got problems with
the co2 footprint and the fact of the
matter is if every lease that's out
there right now they've sold off during
the last government and provincial
government in Alberta they sold off so
many leases that each lease needs a
steam plan if they built every steam
plant that's on the books right now
there's 30 million Canadians if we all
went to zero footprint in other words we
were all able to go to a zero carbon
footprint and all the 30 projects came
on stream Canada would still be out of
compliance for the Kyoto Accord so that
being said I know we're not going to go
to zero footprint if this goes ahead I
figured Canada will have the dirtiest
co2 footprint on the planet so I'm kind
of little upset about that myself
and so that is one of the key things
that there's tons like it's created the
largest surface engineering project on
the planet the largest toxic lakes in
Canada and possibly on the planet as
well and it's the that's the size of the
forest being affected is unprecedented
and they've only touched one percent so
there's ninety nine percent that they
still know of and they haven't explored
the whole region this is another massive
oil field this is a one where they've
seen the movie there will be blood but
this is around Bakersfield this is the
current around the current oil fields
these are the first oil fields that had
been discovered and the beginning of the
big oil boom in California and so again
this is this oil field is still alive
and well still producing over a billion
barrels of oil per year and so but it's
doing doing it through JAC pumps so the
first kind of half of a wells life is
under pressure so they just turn on the
tap when they need it and we don't need
it turn it down a bit but then the
pressure runs out
they're still half the oil down there so
that's when they begin to pump it and
then now what they're doing is they're
doing a similar thing that's happening
in Alberta they're pumping steam down
into the the area where the oil is and
the steam is creating a more viscous
flow of that oil and that oil is coming
up so in a way that landscape of oil and
what brought this dirty century into
being is is is oil and I felt again that
that it was very important to to begin
to show where these key sources of oil
were coming from this is an Azerbaijan
on the Caspian Sea many of you probably
didn't know because I didn't know until
I got there myself
that it's it's there that the offshore
oil platform was invented by a Polish
engineer because the fisherman about 30
kilometers off of the shore of Baku know
knew this place is already rocks and
that there was always the skim of oil on
the surface of the water there so they
knew that there was oil on the land in
Baku so they figured there must be oil
seeping out of the rocks out on the out
on the Caspian Sea how do we get it they
brought in a polish engineer who figured
out how to do an offshore platform it
was about 20 meters deep so these are
all 20 meter kind of stilts they would
take this barge out on to see drop the
stilts built a platform on top start to
drill so it was a fairly easy drill but
it was really the the beginning of
offshore oil and then the back who where
I went on to shore all of that oil field
had been exhausted and exploited and it
was a dead zone a totally dead zone the
water the reflection you're looking at
here is a pool of oil so when the
Russians left this area 20 years ago
because it was largely this oil field
propelled the Russia through the Second
World War and even through the first
world war it was a key resource for and
it was light sweet crude as well which
is the desired oil so this was these are
the fields that fueled the the Russian
Empire during during its last 80
years and it had been left for dead so
this was a dead all field so this is to
me some images of the end of oil so
these are all this is the the great oil
fields again of Baku interestingly
enough what I got here they were at $70
a barrel which is when I was here was 70
bucks a barrel there was still enough to
pump so they started we reigniting a lot
of these wells because even at low
levels they were at that price point
they could make them profitable and I
can imagine that these this thing has
been totally resurrected by now because
of the price of oil at over a hundred
refineries that going further down the
process now the material has been
gathered them into the oil has been
gathered and if we look at any material
in the world in terms of weight if you
look at sand used for buildings or if
you look at stone or if you look at
copper or iron or any of those the
heaviest amount of the most amount of
material the heavies amount of material
that we move on the planet is oil so
refineries all around the world you know
taking that material converting it into
fuels plastics fertilizers all of those
things you know again these are what
those places that we made look like this
is in Texas City the largest refinery
row and in the world I think in terms of
outside of Houston shot from a
helicopter all the tanks were the oil is
being held
this is at a refinery where different
oils come in so if you read the labels
you can see that different types of
crude are coming in got West Texas crude
that can come in you can get stuff from
East Coast Canada you can get stuff you
know whatever you need if you need more
asphalt you can go for sour crude if you
need more high lubricants or high octane
fuels you can get your oil from and so
it's spot price and and the oil refinery
opens and closes the taps based on the
orders from the customers then I began
to also think well what is the direct
outcome of all of this fuel that had
changed our cities had changed our
infrastructure this is in Los Angeles
the 110 and the i-5 I think this is the
intersection of the biggest busiest in
the world and where the freeway was
pretty much invented as well as probably
the suburb so again you know the
development of all this technology the
the fuel created a world in which we
needed we transport ourselves at high
speed fairly high speeds and and and
mobility has been the key driving force
of the middle class so we've actually
been able to create an affluent
middle-class I think directly as a
result of of the automobile being able
to move us around and and the economies
that came out of that of the building of
that infrastructure and the making of
the car and the production and the money
that came from from oil proceeds have
allowed us the to have a large affluent
middle-class what fuels the highways is
cars this is a logistics yard for VW
again showing what you know you know
what is feeding this great
infrastructure and so this is outside of
Houston this is where these are all
Volkswagens the they all appear white
because when they come off the ships
they're coated in white plastic so that
the paint doesn't get scratched and
they deliver them to the dealerships
they pull the white the white plastic
off and and you have a unscratched car
and then again the consequence of of all
these cars are vast collections of the
the waste of the car this is a Melissa
just outside of San Francisco shot in 99
I think around Modesto it's Wesley I
don't know who knows
Wesley's got a small gas station but
it's just in behind tire pile what was
was discovered by me through reading a
book by John McPhee called duty of care
it was an essay in his description the
first paragraph was so compelling I said
I have to go photograph that place and
and this is one of the images I made
from that place and three months after I
photographed it it was hit by lightning
and caught fires you may have heard of
the it was the flames are about they
figured they were at its peak there were
40 million tires and then the the
California Environmental production
agency didn't like that made tires in
one place and they said we've got to
figure out some things they did a pilot
project where they were burning the
tires and creating enough electricity
for 14,000 homes and they had reduced
the pile when I got there the pile had
been reduced from what they figured as
40 million down to about 20 million and
so I was shooting it at its twenty
million scale and then and then three
months after I photographed it got hit
by lightning and it all caught fire in
the project was over the other types of
expressions that I feel are direct
result of not only the production of our
interest that once once we built a big
middle class we needed a way to protect
it and particularly on United States of
America this is in in just outside of
Tucson Arizona an area called a mark
where they have over 4,000 military jets
that are either mothballed in
preparation for active duty you know so
they have everything from the ready in
one week to week three week ten week
three month half a year and some just
four parts and some that are just
decommissioned these are totally
decommissioned transport planes for the
military that would all be will all be
going into recycling but again it's that
incredible infrastructure and the tools
that we've invented to know is protect
our interests and to protect ourselves
from from aggression that that
technology and industrial revolution has
brought this type of expression forward
and these are fighter jets again these
are all decommissioned in the same yards
I went to to photograph the suburb I
thought the fastest-growing suburb in
North America right now is Las Vegas so
I did a flyover vaz Las Vegas last year
to take a look at how the suburb is
expanding and I understand it's
expanding largely because in Nevada has
a very small property tax and it's still
very cheap to and personal tax is still
very cheap to buy a home so a lot of
people might sell a home either here or
in LA and buy something for half the
price and Bank the rest and and live
very inexpensively Lake neat and the
Hoover Dam
again what was interesting to me about
this picture was the the white rim on
the edge of the lake in that it's
beginning to tell a story I think the
lake meters is going down at about six
inches a week it's at its lowest point
ever and if it continues at its current
rate the dam is going to stop being
efficient very soon
and if anything should happen to that
lake the whole idea of Las Vegas is just
a dream
this is shipbreaking in Bangladesh I do
a jump sum this is again directly a
relationship to the Industrial
Revolution to me this is where first
world ships go to die in a third-world
country under very primitive conditions
so it is almost like stepping back and
looking at the world through Dickens
eyes in our current contemporary world
and and the scenes that are created were
so surreal that they seem as if they are
from another world and I felt that that
was somehow and it showed the figures in
the center you know who who were you
know who were the the players within
this theater of the insane
where they're taking down oil tankers
and ships you know with nothing more
than a cutting torch and bare feet and
not even cutting goggles they're just
cutting these ships down and and no
cranes in sight and they're using as
there's a way to bring all the parts up
these are all little winch Hut's up
there all built from salvaged parts of a
ship and that's really the only highest
piece of technology that they have but
everything the whole process is driven
by parts they could find from ships so
then one of the largest engineering
projects on the planet the Three Gorges
Dam I did a project on that and I
thought that would be important to
include in this image as well it's not
only the representative of of China kind
of coming of a coming of age after what
we call a two-year kind of hiatus of
being fairly powerful and significant
and then receding for a couple of years
and now coming back and China even
refers to
this dam is the second Great Wall of
China and so to again represent it in
the gallery I thought would be an
interesting thing to show the scale in
which again man was was what was
operating but but this but this dam
bigger than 50% and probably I would
guess I suspect this will be the biggest
dam ever built I don't think something
this big will ever be attempted again
even when this one was built hmm they
said that there was able they were able
to detect a wobble on the planet when
when they fill the reservoir and each
one of these turbines is 700 megawatts
and nuclear nuclear reactors about a
thousand megawatt so each one of these
is almost a nuclear reactor in terms of
power output and they have 32 of these
turbines so it is a massive massive
project and if you ever get to see the
print itself you can see small figures
all throughout this working way like
ants in a massive ant farm again
where all of our products coming from
this is a big running shoe factory you
know the 90 what is it the total
workforce for the You Yangs shoe factory
was 250,000 this particular compound had
45,000 workers and this is 20,000 of
them going to dinner
so that's quite something
again China coal key a key a key
material and a key energy source for
China and again one of the things I
think you know if we look at all the
things that are happening out there to
me coal is the the scariest of them all
in terms of you know there's a they say
about a thousand megawatt dirty coal
burning power station being built per
week in China and they're still being
built all over the place in North
America and and each one of those dirty
coal burying thousand megawatt plants is
going to be there for 40 years spewing
who the worst that we can imagine out
into the air so I think coal is the the
real dirty secret out there in terms of
how we're you know if we're gonna stem
global warming and the co2 accumulation
in the atmosphere we're going to have to
stare this one in the eye again in China
I've always kind of liked this picture
in that this woman is almost a hundred
years old she's been through four great
changes in China from the dynasty to the
Republic from the Republic to the
Communists and from the Communists to
the what I call the authoritarian
capitalist system of today and here she
is on her stoop with a waste as industry
on her front porch and this is again a
waste where they're taking all the chips
and and removing moving the chips and
recycling all the precious metals off
the chips and then they're grinding
these circuit boards and taking all the
last metals off of that and and then and
that's the end process end line of
computers and computer boards in China
so 50 percent of all our computers that
are recycled are recycled in China this
gives you a bit of a snapshot not that I
think video is going to be in
and in the 10,000 gallery but it's a an
interesting piece of sound on that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so she does 400 those a day and
that's why we can't compete with that
anymore because they're not using
robotics they're using this massive
workforce and and they're highly
motivated because there's they think in
in China there's a mobile community of
about a hundred million that are looking
to find work in from the rural into the
urban centers so the pressure on these
workers to to to output every day it's
severe because there's so many workers
looking to take their job now this is
the the biggest mobile phone company
producing phones in China birdmobile
this is a lunchroom of the largest
garment factory young or in in China the
biggest chicken packing plant I could
find in China which produced they
dressed out and produced processed 100
million chickens a year which sounds
like a lot but actually asked the
question well how many live fowl would
there be in China every given day of the
year and on a daily basis they estimate
between five point five and six billion
fowl are alive and in husbandry mode in
China so the processing of 100 million
is actually a very slow and I thought a
hundred million if so the chicken feeds
a family of four then the year the
output of this whole plant would be
enough to feed a third of China for one
meal which just gives a bit of
perspective
and this is again a large factory 22,000
people producing coffee makers and irons
for ironing they did 22 million irons
and 3 million coffee makers a year this
is the inside of the coffee making plant
if any of you have seen the movie
manufactured landscapes there's an 8
minute opening shot it's basically a
dolly shot from there all the way along
there show it you know pointing into the
aisles of this particular plant where
they're making coffee makers so it's
it's an opening shot that's gotten a lot
of acclaim in terms of how to take a
still image and unpack it and and show
through film what it still is trying to
show in a singular combined image but
again the size of a factory floor in in
in the new and that's what I saw it
found interesting about China and why I
wanted to bring into the idea as well
the gallery is that a lot of this is the
invention from here from the West and
what's happened is that it's been
unbolted from the factory floor here
taken to China amplified to you know to
a factor of 10 because they're supplying
back to the world and the population has
been growing ever since
and and that these manifestations are
now apparent there but they're their
source is actually of the assembly line
the production lines the extrusion
machines all of that the plastics the
materials are all I think mostly Western
invention and then the cities of Asia
that have grown up Shanghai Hong Kong
that sound effects
and again that density of of living and
then as a kind of concluding image this
kind of forest of what I call the
International style gone crazy
I don't think Bauhaus that the Bauhaus
guys ever intended it to look like this
actually when they developed a high-rise
for high-density living there was
supposed to be part of almost equal
floor space for natural walks and to be
able to enjoy the outdoors with a
high-density living they obviously cut
out the second part of the equation on
most of this so that's the presentation
and so now I think we're to do some Q&A
[Applause]
[Music]
formidable it's going to be interesting
to see what these images look like in a
hundred years time a thousand years time
and ten thousand years time because the
what took you to these places was sort
of evident in the kind of the essay that
you tell aren't each one of them this is
the largest something-or-other this is
the most damaging something-or-other
it's the most extractive
something-or-other and the images by
themselves they're so big they're so
rich they're so detailed they're so real
that a person walks up to them and the
first thing they're doing is you know
they're going in closer look at that
little tiny person if what's going on
and they tell themselves a story what's
going on there without necessarily your
valence on it that this is a bad story
and the Three Gorges Dam it's incredible
it's terrible a couple million people
moved you know there's what did you say
32 dams under construction now in China
all this kind of thing each time a
horrible problem but on the other hand
Wow and you know I have a feeling people
will look at these things in future time
and it's like us looking at sailing
ships you know the big the tall ships we
got someone coming in shortly and you
know it was wrong buggery in the lash
for the guys were on the vessels right
it was a floating prison on which on
which you might get drowned but we look
at those things Wow how do they do that
it's incredible so I've a feeling this
kind of imagery you're dead right is
exactly the sort of thing to launch
through time and my guess is that the
same thing happened with the cave
paintings that you know they had one set
of things in mind but then an important
thing to remember about the cave
paintings and it's what your ten
thousand year gallery would get at is
there was the first set of cane
paintings but people kept going back
into those caves and they'd see the
former images and go yeah well and then
sort of you know right right over it or
do a reply or something like that so
their art was about art they already
knew that this was communication through
time so the characters who are curating
and contributing to the 10,000 year
gallery are going to have the sense of
as that early stuff and what was in
their mind but hitting onto got my own
interpretation of it they're going to be
responding over centuries and millennia
to the sequence of images in the
sequence of interpretations that sound
right to you
I would I would think that and it's it's
as you accumulate as these images
accumulate that they're there is kind of
pressure because obviously you know of
the very early ones of the very you know
the first ones in it's the the it's
fairly open it's an open text kind of
just lay down what you think but once
you lay marks down then people respond
not only to the the task at hand but the
marks that have been laid and so then
their marks have the added pressure of
trying to either aspire to beat the
marks that have been laid to match them
or or you know and what they're trying
to not do is have something that would
be considered inferior to what's already
been put in play and there are only I
guess so many human stories to so some
of the big great stories get you know
told very quickly and that's why I
thought that's showing the gallery the
mundane is interesting too because there
are like shards these are like what
archeologists tend to their stock and
trade of what they find when they do
digs are little bits and pieces of our
daily life and not these great gestures
of human ambition and so I think there
is you know all these things are are
part of a process of bringing in other
thinkers and curators to to consider
what's there and consider what can be or
what hasn't been told yet there's a
question from Michael M wave your hand
what is the history of the carbon image
process you propose to use how did he
evolve what needed at fill he mentioned
just three places doing it is that
growing or dwindling and
if all this happens will it help it grow
well I mean the the the I would say
rather than get into the whole history I
mean it was first discovered in the
mid-1800s and there were some French
which the names avoid mirror I can't
quite get but if you go to the actually
art and soul website the one that and
just go art and soil carbon printing
carbon transfer printing it's got a
beautiful synopsis of the history there
that's where I was showing you the
images as well so that that would
certainly help fill in any kind of gaps
as to the history it is very but it's
early process and and it is a dwindling
there's very very few who are willing to
commit the kind of time and energy to to
produce these things today so it is a
dying artisan craft and and it would be
wonderful I think to keep it alive at
least until technology can merge and
find a replacement for it because
ultimately I think these materials will
be get harder and harder like even the
gelatin they had to this gelatin here
the purity of this gelatin and that's
this particular gelatin it's not any
other gelatin there's one factory that's
making this gelatin and they make it
special order for the two guys and the
three guys have pulled together and they
get cases of it made because nobody else
needs this purity and if you don't have
this purity you can get yellowing and
get problems and and imperfections in
the coatings therefore causing dimples
in the in the actual print so and these
are there's there's this handful of guys
right now that are keeping it alive and
will do so I guess as long as but but
they're all like I've looked at every
one of them they're all over 50 so and I
don't see any young apprentices around
here either so so there's there is this
kind of moment that we're at where this
could very well as a process
disappear if you know certain people
don't try to or find a reason to keep it
alive
well this particular print here if you
put that out in the Sun not in the
community control temperature controlled
storage all this is put on the Sun like
a car how long would it last
um I think it would do as well as a car
you know which would be like you know
probably 3040 years before you start
seeing fading Wow
you know or significant fading you said
some guy did an accelerated yeah did a
tests where if you look they did a test
for the average viewing wall of a print
starting in the northern hemisphere and
all the way down to the equator and they
averaged what a living room wall would
would would get as a Lux value and it
was somewhere averaged around 125 Lux
value Henry will hem does his tests at
450 Lux which is about four times that
not intensity 12 hours a day so he does
it for 12 hours a day 12 hours on 12
hours off 365 days a year
he did that level testing for 500 years
on this print and figured this shift was
less than 1% all right so it's about as
solid as you're gonna get yeah I think
this is something you know that spread
the word collectors museums should want
this quality of archival material and if
they request it and pay for it it's not
that much more expensive than regular
good prints it sounds like we could keep
this process going and getting better
over time now I think a lot of people
were fascinated by the mundane gallery
mm-hm and it was actually smart to draw
something from the 1950s or 60s that we
already feel sort of archival about but
one of the questioners says wouldn't it
be interesting to you know
it really clicks stuff randomly which is
actually the sort of stuff that you do
find in archaeological digs and so on so
doing you'll send out a random trawl on
the net for images and bring those
things back and then you know give them
this treatment and so you know of all
the stuff that's on or a particular
minute on Flickr you know one umpteenth
of that becomes the right the record of
this time and maybe you do another one
in ten years and compare and contrast it
wouldn't be Flickr then there'll be
something else but is that a way to
approach mundane well I I think so I I
think because ultimately what what we
actually find interesting and I think
you know we're caught in a current you
know of you know intense information
things flying by us at incredible speeds
trying to keep up to it in our
individual lives so it's very hard to
kind of pull out of that current and to
think well what would be interesting you
know as a shard to leave behind you know
what and what speaks about our value
system because I think that value system
is probably one of the most interesting
things to leave a record of what was it
that we aspired to what was it that we
desired what was it that that you know
what about sneer at like graffiti yeah
people look at old magazines they're not
so interested in the article so the
illustration is what they really study
is the ads you know which is you know at
the time we're going right by those if
we can yeah they're what's paying for
the system and they're also its most
fascinating later why is that
I think cuz we're always interested in
the fact that as human beings there's
something enduring about us that that
were always interested in you know and
the similar things like there was I
remember going into the Orkneys once and
we went to an old it was a mound and it
was a Viking graveyard and there was
graffiti in and then somebody's is
deciphered at all and it was mostly
gossip you know like you know
who was a girl to chase at the time and
all this guy and so they interpreted it
all and then every sec fascinated with
the fact that that you know their mind
you know the guys minds are in the exact
same spot you know you know three
thousand years ago you know and so so i
think that you know whenever we can see
something that crosses millennia that
says we haven't really changed that much
as a as a kind of a human animal that
we're still interested in similar things
that we still have that kind of
day-to-day life that we have to service
and we do it differently but it's still
servicing our day-to-day lives you know
it all of the cave paintings in the
glyphs and the stuff they're drawing in
all the caves there's always lots and
lots of vaginas and big what's important
today yeah it's clear so actually
pornography will be part of the record
but i show some pornography from pompeii
and that's considered one of the great
highlights yeah pompeii to go see where
the brothels were you know there you are
nothing changed when roberts has a
question how was your Ted wish unfolded
which one I don't know I was in the
three vicious oh that was right okay so
I wasn't to convince them to go to one
because three was like inheriting three
big job tell the story um well they're
all in different states this was 2004
right well it's a 2005 - I was I heard
about it 2004 and there was a bunch of
money involved a hundred thousand
dollars three whishes any of the kid
prizes then it was three wishes on a
bunch of money and a pretty rich and
capable audience at the TED conference
in Monterey and the idea was to harness
all of that talent and interest to help
out the winner make his wish happens
yeah and I think I think what's
interesting is I kind of surprised Chris
Anderson who's the well he was the the
show curator and owns the show as well
Ted the TED conference and and I think
what he expected even told me expected
that as an artist I would somehow be
able to be interested in taking my
work and using that audience to help
disseminate that work into the world and
he was surprised when I told that that's
not what I wanted to do you know that
ultimately as a fine artist I had felt
that my work was already gaining
traction out there and you know when
somebody says you you know go out there
and make three three big wishes that can
change the world think big and then to
then direct all of the or direct them at
me and my work to make my work popular I
thought there's something you know a
little self-serving in that whole
approach so I converted my thinking into
trying to say well what's you know if
we're gonna change the world number one
I thought well if it's that easy to
change the world why haven't we done it
if a hundred thousand dollars and few
wishes can do it but but but it still it
was a chance to kind of begin to grapple
with you know what was a possibility so
the three things that I ended up
thinking about one was how do we begin
to disseminate information and and
trying to find something that was
happening at the time that made sense
and so one of the wishes was to take a
site called world changing some of you
may have heard of it row changing calm
they produced a book called world
changing the user's guide to the 21st
century which was an abram got about a
little yeah so that was again part of
the outcome of that to get that going
and I think for a while that worked
pretty well and I had a bit of a flare
out and it's now starting to kind of
come back again slowly and maybe in a
more sane and careful approach but I
think it on the outside it did do many
things to start bringing the
conversation what I liked about that is
it was an open concept where people
could post what was working out there it
wasn't a [ __ ] session but it was what
can we do to create a more sustainable
world here the good ideas and models for
that for the fur for a sustainable world
so so that was one the other thing I
thought is bringing and they all
everything had to do with raising
consciousness the other one was
- how do we get the kids start thinking
sustainably and I started with the idea
of a I think all in my world having kids
teach them about sustainable thinking
and a fun and an easygoing way we
finally got D at WGBH in Boston to jump
on it and we got some funders from the
Ted the buyers jumped into it and
created a site called meet the greens
and it's like a family greens and the
kids are actually far more
environmentally astute and and not how
to how to function in saving water
recycling and all that then the parents
are and so it's this constant push back
from the kids to the parents about
building a more sustainable world in a
fun way
so that's currently evolving and
developing as a site and growing as a
site and WGBH if you don't know it is
one of the larger producers of public
broadcasting in the United States and
it's now coming up through a feed
through TV Ontario as well as it's
coming up into Canada as well and of
course the web is international and the
third one was to do an IMAX film but it
never ended up being an IMAX film
manufactured landscapes ended up getting
a bit of the updraft of wanting to do a
film based on my work so I so I did get
a lot of support around it when it came
to to producing the film and I still
think that one day I'd like to still
produce a film based on the themes that
I've done except doing it in a large
format version I suspect by the time I
do get to that stage there may be a
digital solution to shooting on that
that high resolution and projecting it
large and showing our world filmic ly
and what I'm doing as a set of still so
that's still in progress going live just
two more questions I should mention
there are signed copies of Ed's Corey's
book in the lobby which I recommend to
you and if you go over to the reception
the book that long now sells called the
world without us the world without us is
in written journalistic form the sort of
thing about infrastructure that ed
Burtynsky has been doing with photo
laughs this is basically thinking
through if people suddenly weren't here
one day what would be the changes over
time to everything to buildings to
infrastructure to all these things and
it's a wonderfully detailed and well
researched travelogue basically to all
places in the world that show how things
would proceed so it's got the
infrastructural level that you do two
questions one is you're now using more
video YouTube is huge and getting huger
and I'll just flicker and there's you
too well you've taken care of archival
Flickr your next task is to figure out
archival video you know how can you do
some kind of moving images with sound
that is basically a platform free enough
or platform set in stone enough so that
that can be seen over time well I think
the problem even gets bigger than that
in that the assumption that you know
even a thousand years from now that the
sources of energy are going to be
anything close to what we have now in
terms of being able to feed this
equipment to be able to replay the
things the thing is that it's so I mean
the replay of a print like that is you
open your eyes and you put some light on
it that's pretty straightforward replay
and the minute you get any media any
player and the source of power to mesh
up with all of that so I mean I can't
imagine a thousand you even 500 years
from now that the source of power will
look anything like this you know 120
volts 60 cycles you know that might be a
whole other DC type thing that this
thing that we even if you kept the
player dry and they're you know waiting
for power to playback the thing that you
want or even a computer that can play it
back the fact that the stuff that will
be around that can actually you know
respond to it maybe a bigger question so
the whole idea of the more
technologically sophisticated it is I
think the the more difficult it is to
have a deep future
you know that there's a danger of either
file formats or technology or power
sources not meshing and that you have
the intelligence of the skill or the
will to go back and reverse engineer it
and to find out what it needed from back
then to bring it up on screen which may
be obviously very simple enough to do if
if the equipment's there if all the
circuitry and all the boards and all
this stuff hasn't detected Tier II to
the point where it won't play in in
several thousand years which stated the
problem very well and the solution
obviously remains to be found if any one
question I got it from a couple people
just a quick when can this carbon print
process transfer process be used on say
the walls of the chamber if there are
some images that you know people just
absolutely want to have there and we can
it's very fine grain limestone it's
almost marble so we can polish it as
fine as you want could this stuff go so
good guy yep you can just saw you use a
gelatin for gelatin coating on it mm-hmm
the gelatin work with porcelain and
limestone anything like that it'll it'll
get large long fingers into that and
then you you wet the surface you roll
the print on you let it dry and then the
release paper has less of a tension or
less of a stickiness than the thing that
you're you're putting it against then
you pull the plastic back they pull it
the release paper off and you now have a
permanent print on a wall let's do that
you're a working artist in full stride
of what's coming next
another big exhibition in in Washington
at the Corcoran we're going to be
launching a lot of this stuff I showed
you about kind of the landscape of oil
I also subtitle it the oil party you
know like the whole notion that we're at
this kind of no showing in the
Washington State for your part of the
parties so it is very much looking at
that landscape trying to find ways in
which its presented itself to me over
time that I think is relevant to put
together into a
book of images that kind of be and some
essays I begin to cap encapsulate how
our lives and our and our urban
landscape and our kind of middle class
has been shaped by not only the
Industrial Revolution but this
incredible source of energy that and
that is here for both good and bad that
has allowed us to achieve what we have
so to me you know you know and I had
kind of this idea of oil in 1997 but I
think by it's been about onine when I'm
showing it'll be twelve years where I've
worked on the project so I'm trying to
bring it to to kind of a closure to try
and somehow put it into a book and and
as my quarry book has brought things
together the china book to do one an oil
now on the oil business and they would
describe what you've just gone over as
downstream and what's the oil is found
the things you do to get it out in the
world what's upstream for you what do
you want to shoot what do I've been
shooting i I just photograph something
very different than I normally do I I
just went to CERN and photograph these
at particle accelerator great which is
really exciting to see and the content
that's kind of an up project that is a
more up project is kind of you know why
does anything exist question and but
I've been again looking more into the
new processes that are out there video
I'm starting to look at you know
capturing sound and video and using my
themes a little bit more and trying to
see how that might work into my work and
I'm pretty excited about some of the
technology that's coming on stream in
terms of the digital technology the new
like the Sony h3 you know you could put
on really good lenses and you're at a
level of almost film quality at just
above $10,000 you know video camera so
the the ability I think to work at the
kind of quality level that I like to
and that's what's often helped me back
is Sioux jump into 35-millimeter film as
you know that you know you're into huge
budgets a lot of limitations you know in
rentals and so you have to be spending
most of your time raising the funds to
do these things whereas the new
technology is going to allow artists
like myself with means but not those
kind of means to be able to continue to
produce work in my own way at my own
pace without a lot of pressure around me
to be able to produce you know projects
that that I think can be very exciting
and and again bridging those kinds of
worlds that I tended to do
photographically but expanding the
medium through which I do it through
just sounded motion fantastic thank you
all right
[Applause]
[Music]